متجاهلا تصريحات وتلميحات الحلفاء الاقرب
لاسرائيل لا يتردد رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو في تاكيد رفضه القاطع لاقامه دوله
فلسطينيه والتفاخر بانه من حال دون قيامها
على مدى سنوات طويله لينضم بذلك الى
تصريحات تلاحقت خلال الساعات الماضيه
لوزراء اقصى اليمين في
حكومته ورغم الغموض الذي يكتنف حتى الان
الاجابه على سؤال متى وكيف ستنتهي الحرب
الحاليه فان نتنياهو لا يتردد ايضا
بالتاكيد على ان السيطره الامنيه على غزه
مستقبلا ستكون لاسرائيل بعد تحويلها بحسب
كلماته لمنطقه منزوعه
السلاح غزه يجب ان تكون منزوعه السلاح
وتحت السيطره الكامله لدوله اسرائيل ولن
اتنازل كذلك عن السيطره الامنيه
الاسرائيليه الكامله على كل الاراضي
الواقعه غرب الاردن
بصفه رئيسا لوزراء اسرائيل فقد وقفت بثبات
الى جانب هذا الموقف في مواجهه الضغوط
الدوليه والداخليه الكبيره اسراري هو الذي
حال دون قيام دوله فلسطينيه لسنوات طويله
والتي كانت ستشكل خطر وجوديا على
اسرائيل موقف ياتي معاكسا لطروحات
واشنطن بل ومناقض لكلام الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن قبل يومين بانه لمس تفاهما من
نتنياهو لحل الدولتين وان سعى منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي جون كيربي للتخفيف من
دلالاته لا يزال الرئيس بايدن متفائلا جدا
بشان امكانيه تحقيق حل الدولتين ويعتقد
انه الطريق الامثل للمضي قدما نحو تحقيق
السلام والامن في المنطقه بالتاكيد سيعود
ذلك بفائده كبيره على الشعب الفلسطيني لكن
الرئيس يعتقد ايضا ان حل الدولتين يصب في
مصلحه الشعب الاسرائيلي والان لدينا
نتنياهو وهو رئيس وزراء اسرائيل المنتخب
ونحن نحترمه والرئيس بايدن يعرفه وعمل معه
منذ وقت طويل لكنهما بالتاكيد لا يتفقان
في كل جوانب
السياسه لكن وزير الدفاع البريطاني جران
شابس بدا اكثر صراحه في رد فعله على موقف
نتنياهو واصفا اياه بانه مخيب للغايه شابس
جدد التاكيد على ان بلاده لا ترى طريقا
اخر لانهاء الصراع سوى حل الدولتين في حين
يسعى الاتحاد الاوروبي الى ما هو اكثر من
التعبير عن الاستياء من تصريحات نتنياهو
اذ ينتظر ان يبحث وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
عواقب قد تواجهها اسرائيل في حال الاصرار
على موقفها الرافض لحل الدولتين ربما يكون
من بينها بحسب مصادر للجزيره سحب امتيازات
تتمتع بها وفقا للاتفاقيه المشتركه مع
الاتحاد
الاوروبي بموازاه هذه التطورات عقده
الاسرى وغموض المالات والمحادثات تزيد
الضغوط تصل اصوات المتظاهرين الغاضبين الى
مقر اقامه
نتنياهو فبعد مظاهرات في تل ابيب وحيفا
والقدس طالب بعضها باستقاله حكومته بدات
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين في غزه
اعتصاما مفتوحا في محيط مقر اقامته
للمطالبه بابرام صفقه فوريه لتبادل الاسرى
تحركات قد يزداد زخمها مع تواصل الرسائل
القادمه من كتائب القسام بشان مصير الاسرى
لديها تضمنت احداثها صوره تظهر رساله تمسك
بها يد جندي اسرائيلي مكتوبا عليها كنت
مستميتا في الدفاع عن الدوله وهي ملزمه
باعادته الى حضن
عائلتي